And the answer is depressing.
If you, once again, draw the truth table,
you find, for the different combinations,
that if you've drawn coin 1,
you'd never see tails.
So this case over here, which indeed has tails, tails.
We have 0 probability.
We can work this out probability of drawing the first coin at 0.5,
but the probability of tails given the first coin
must be 0, because the probability of heads is 1,
so 0.5 times 0 times 0,
that is 0.
So the only case where you might see tails/tails is
when you actually drew coin 2,
and this has a probability of
0.5 times the probability of tails
given that we drew the second coin,
which is 0.4 times 0.4 again,
and that's the same as 0.08
would have been the correct answer.